Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Geschichten ist das ein bisschen anders also wir sind gerade bei der Frage hier weil Sachen
die quasi wo es egal ist oder wo es nicht egal ist also wo es nicht drauf ankommt so
richtig ob der Kram in der richtigen Reihenfolge ankommt oder dass alles ankommt dann macht
man das nicht weil es ist theoretisch zumindest die Performance besser und wenn man sich überlegt
man hat so was wie eine Live-Feed von Audio oder eine Live-Feed von einem Video oder eben
auch Daten von einem Spiel und ich bekomme jetzt Pakete geschickt vom Server und es kommt
keine Ahnung es kommt Paket 10 an vor Paket 9 dann wäre es ja eigentlich logisch irgendwo
oder es ist eigentlich logisch dass ich dann mit Paket 9 nichts mehr anfangen kann also
wenn Paket zu spät ankommt ist egal und es bringt auch nichts wenn ich Paket 9 neu anfordere
wenn es überhaupt nicht ankommt weil was interessiert mich Bilddaten von vor zwei Sekunden
wenn ich schon aktuelle Bilddaten habe oder bei Spielen was interessiert mich dass vor
zwei Sekunden irgendjemand da den Noobtube abgeschossen hat wenn der Server-Stage schon
viel weiter ist also deswegen wirkt sich halt wenn man überhaupt Packet Loss hat wirkt
sich das eben auf solche Sachen natürlich dann auch besonders aus man muss allerdings
sagen wenn du 10% Packet Loss hast ist wahrscheinlich alles davon betroffen das kann natürlich
auch sein dass das nur auftritt wenn du besonders viele Pakete schickst nichtsdestotrotz verursachen
Spiele nicht viel Traffic ist YouTube UDP oder TCP YouTube ist sowas von TCP weil YouTube
ist HTTP was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen ja also es kann sein dass das natürlich erst
auftritt wenn du besonders viele Pakete verschickst oder dass dein Provider Probleme kriegt allerdings
auch wenn es irgendwie das Gerücht sich hartnäckig hält dass Spiele irgendwie sonderlich ressourcen
intensiv wären das betrifft nicht den Netzwerk Part also Spiele verbrauchen so gut wie kein
Netzwerk Traffic es sei denn das ist so ein bisschen veraltete Architektur wie das zum
Beispiel immer noch in Call of Duty ist dass irgendwie einer der Leute selbst das Spiel
hostet wobei das in Call of Duty glaube ich auch nicht mehr überall der Fall ist aber
bei dem Stream den wir gestern gesehen haben war das wieder so wenn du jetzt selbst die
Sache hostest dann brauchst du natürlich deutlich mehr Netzwerk Traffic also logisch
man dann musst du ja quasi an die ganzen Typen die auch bei dir in Session join das verteilen
aber in normalen Spielen ist das nicht der Fall das heißt in normalen Games braucht
Spielen kaum Netzwerk Traffic und es ist relativ wahrscheinlich dass du bei allem deine 10%
Packet Loss hast allerdings das was man wirklich gut feststellen kann musst du schonmal eine
ordentliche Menge an Paketen schicken und es ist auch die Frage ab wann der Loss als
Loss zählt letztendlich weil wie ich gesagt habe in Spielen wenn du da Pakete kriegst
die nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge sind und du dann irgendwann mal das Paket kriegst
was theoretisch reinpassen würde in die Reihenfolge dann ist es egal weil dann ist da sowas
steht eh schon weiter ein Ping kann durchaus oder darf durchaus auch mal eine Sekunde unterwegs
sein was natürlich bei einem Spiel irgendwie recht bescheuert ist Trace Route sagt mir
dass ich bei zwei Vodafone Servern rund 30% habe die meinen halt dass das normal sei weil
der Server beschädigt ist und die Anfrage verwirft und ich hätte am Zielserver kein
Loss dass ich Schwachsinn ich kann mir vorstellen was die meinen ich kann mir vorstellen was
die meinen aber die Aussage an sich von Vodafone ist Schwachsinn also was damit gemeint ist
muss man sich erstmal angucken wie Trace Route funktioniert jetzt mal rhetorische Frage
wissen alle wie Trace Route funktioniert ich hoffe nicht weil da kann ich jetzt erklären
es gibt verschiedene Varianten wie Trace Route funktioniert aber ich erkläre mal die verbreitetste
Variante
ne also wenn du unterwegs Packet Loss hast Main hast du zum Ziel auch also auf dir gleich
eine gute Packet Loss das kann nicht sein dass ein Paket verloren geht zwischendurch
und dann auf einmal beim Ziel wieder ankommt das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn was die
meinen ist dass die Server unterwegs schlicht und ergreifend auf deine ICMP Pakete nicht
antworten und deswegen im Trace Route drinnen steht dass du den dass du na wenn du Trace
Route machst keine Ahnung aber Trace Route dann hast du Server die halt keine ICMP antworten
schicken da muss ich jetzt aber mal kurz zu erklären wie Trace Route prinzipiell oder
wie gehen warum mache ich was ist eigentlich was ist eigentlich mit mir kaputt dass ich
das unter Windows mache eh geh mal fort Trace Route was nehmen wir mal schönes Battle Net
so Battle Net so wenn ich halt Trace Route mache was auch immer das für krasse Domains
sind unterwegs oder Trace Route wie der Cisco Fan sagt da sieht man unterwegs so Dinger
hier wenn du so Dinger siehst heißt das nicht dass du Packet Loss hast wenn du so Dinger
siehst heißt das nur dass das dass der Server an dieser Stelle nicht auf deine Pakete antwortet
die Trace Route schickt der nächste antwortet wieder Trace Route funktioniert folgendermaßen
du hast in einem Paket hast du einen Setting das nennt sich TTL das ist so die die Standard
Trace Route Implementierung du hast ein Setting in deinem Paket das nennt sich TTL das steht
für Time to Live wenn du dieses wenn das gesetzt ist und ein Router kriegt das ich
meine jeder jeder Hopp hier auf dem Weg ist ist quasi ein Router oder hier bei jedem Hopp
wird ein Paket einmal geroutet also da das ist meins hier das ist das ist die das ist
Unity Media die Unity Media Box bei mir also das ist mein Mikrotik Router das ist die Unity
Media Box das ist irgendwas dahinter von Unity Media was nicht antwortet so und Trace Route
funktioniert folgendermaßen du setzt die TTL auf 1 dann kriegt das dieser Router und
antwortet dir ei TTL 1 ich kann das Paket nicht weiterleiten weil TTL überschritten
wurde dann schickt ihr dieser Router schickt in der Nachricht zurück und sagt Alter ich
hab dein Paket wegwerfen müssen so danach schickt Trace Route das gleiche Paket nochmal
mit TTL 2 jetzt muss der nächste Router in der Kette dein Paket wegwerfen weil TTL exited
und dann antwortet dir der Router ei Alter ich hab dein Paket weg geworfen und der dritte
Router in dem Fall hier also das wahrscheinlich das erste nach meinem Netz bei Unity Media
der sagt wenn er mein Paket kriegt nichts der verwirft das Paket weil da drin steht
TTL 3 der verwirft das Paket aber der sagt mir nicht das er es verworfen hat und weil
er mir nicht sagt das er es verworfen hat kann ich nicht mehr erkennen welcher Router
das ist diese Sternchen hier bedeuten nicht dass du Paketloss hast das hat damit nichts
zu tun die Sternchen bedeuten nur wir müssen uns mal gucken wie das Ding unter Windows
aussieht ist ein bisschen langsamer also gute Frage keine Ahnung was das ist ok Windows
Trace Route ist ein bisschen langsamer ich glaube Windows Trace Route macht das auch
so wie ich es erklärt habe ich glaube das Linux Trace Route macht standardmäßig kein
ICMP Time to Live Trace Route gedröhnt ich glaube das macht irgendeine UDP Geschichte
aber das weiß ich wie ich es erklärt habe diese ICMP Time to Live Geschichte ist so
die Standard Trace Route Implementierung die man auch immer so lernt ja ja aorta.net das
ist kein Schimmer ich würde sagen wenn es Frankfurt ist würde ich sagen irgendwas vom
Dezix aber die haben glaube ich einen anderen Domain DEFRA04D keine Ahnung aber das hier
das hier wie gesagt bedeutet nicht dass du Paketloss hast das bedeutet nur dass dieser
Router an dieser Stelle nicht antwortet auf deine Pakete von Trace Route so und wie kommst
du jetzt da drauf dass du 30% oder 30% Paketloss hast zeigt dir das an oder was muss ich mal
gucken was Windows Trace Route am Ende so anzeigt warum hast du die Zeugensuche auf Twitter
retweeted hast du damit was zu tun ja nur weil du was retweetest musst natürlich gleich
daran beteiligt sein ne ich retweet öfters war es von der Polizei in Frankfurt und ich
würde denken vielleicht hat jemand was gesehen Pingplotter ok also es kann es kann eigentlich
nicht sein dass du Paketloss unterwegs hast und am Ziel nicht das ergibt überhaupt keinen
Sinn wenn du die gleiche Route verwendest und du hast Paketloss auf der Route dann kommt
dein Paket nicht an also es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn zu sagen es gibt überhaupt keinen
Sinn zu sagen ja du verlierst an einem Hop 30% Pakete aber beim Ziel hast du kein Paketloss
das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn wenn auf dieser Route irgendwo 30% Paketloss auftreten
hast du auf allen Hops dahinter natürlich auch diese 30% Paketloss weil die Pakete
sind ja weg irgendwie logisch aber 10% Paketloss sind auch ganz schön viel was wie kommst du
denn überhaupt auf die Idee das zu test hast du irgendwie Probleme in Spielen sind 245
zu zu battle net ein bisschen hoch doch irgendwie schon mal gucken wie weit es mit Ping ist
ja blizzard ist huge langsam gerade ich weiß gar nicht ob bettel.net ist bettel.net überhaupt
die blizzard geschichte das heißt zwar so aber doch die seite ist auch übelst langsam
guckt euch das mal an blizzard ist langsam ich habe können wir aber schnelleres nehmen
so hier oder oder hier ein wubblords.tv nehmen das ist ordentlich schnell oder 1111 können
wir nehmen das ist auch ordentlich umschwanken das so eigentlich das ist bestimmt jetzt
so ein unity media wie geht denn wie geht denn das unter windows t9 wie macht man unter
windows unendlich lang ping einfach nur minus t warum warum sind die pingzeiten wenn ich
minus t mache anders als ohne minus t ok jetzt was auch immer wahrscheinlich frag mich nicht
ja doch irgendwie schwankt ganz schön das könnte auch das könnte sie in unity media
geschichte sein kannst du ein tracer zu wubblords.tv machen können wir auch machen ja das ist
schön stabil ja bisschen das ist ok ok mein ja das ist das ist sehr schwierig zu diagnostizieren
remote mein ob du bei dir wirklich packetloss hast kannst du ja einfach probieren du kannst
entweder mal bei dir einen raspberry anschöpseln an deinen router und zwischen zwischen deinem
rechner und dem raspberry machst du einfach einen ip perf oder ip perf ach ein trace
und soll ja wubblos machen das kannst du machen oder aber du mietest dir mal irgendwie für
fünf minuten den server bei digital ocean oder irgendwie sowas halt wo man weiß dass
die auch eine gute anbindung haben und machst dann mal einen ip perf zwischen dir und diesem
server dann wirst du ja sehen wo das auftritt das ist schon geiler domain name für netzwerk
kram warum sie baro ich finde digital ocean nicht schlecht das ist super easy zu verwenden
drauf gehen rechner anlegen anklicken benutzen für zehn minuten wieder ausmachen und bezahlste
am ende dann eben 35 cent oder so das ist halt auch nicht teuer scaleway habe ich noch
nicht verwendet ja nur die meda geht über s s 6 4 5 3 ich habe keine ahnung sie baue
ich habe jetzt irgendwas gesagt aber es ist nicht teuer wahrscheinlich viel billiger
ich weiß nicht was bei digital ocean kostet gerade das wirst du auf jeden das wirst du
jetzt ein bisschen genauer analysieren das kann man kann man jetzt wie gesagt remote
schlecht sagen aber wenn du testen willst ob es wirklich an dir liegt dann würde ich
einfach an der kiste wo dein ausgang ist was anstöpseln und gucken ob zwischen deinem
desktop und dieser kiste ob es da auch pergelost gibt dann kannst du ja schon mal ausschließen
dass es irgendwie an dir liegt aber wo davon ist auch nicht gerade dafür bekannt jetzt
qualitativ so der beste anbieter zu sein ich weiß es sind letztendlich alle anbieter nicht
dafür bekannt alle anbieter haben genug probleme aber wo davon ist von dem was ich an was ich
vor leuten hören was ich überhaupt was man sich auch an berichten und wenn man das bewertung
und user erfahrung angucken kann nicht oben mit dabei habe ich eigentlich erzählt dass
ich jetzt mein telekom anschluss endlich gekündigt habe es hat auch keine keine halbe stunde
gedauert da hat die telekom telekom kundenrückgewinnungs hotline dudes angerufen und wollte mir dann
erzählen dass das ja furchtbar schade ist dass ich von der telekom wechseln will und
ob ich nicht wüsste das hat das hat er wirklich gefragt ob ich nicht wüsste wer der premium
anbieter in deutschland ist bescheuerte frage habe ich gesagt ok lass mich verraten also
sie rufen von der telekom an da kann ja der einzige premium anbieter nur die telekom
sein oder ja und das kommt nicht von ungefähr hat er dann gesagt schüren auch gerade bescheuerter
grund die leute an die gekündigt haben fragen ob sie nicht wissen wer der premium anbieter
ist weil was was genau soll ein premium anbieter überhaupt sein selbst der für dir das zeug
ja nice madrigs 1337 ich hoffe bei einem gescheiten land premium gleich teuer ja aber
telekom ist jetzt gekündigt ich habe ab am nächsten monat wie viel kontakt hast du
noch mit dem friseur regelmäßig ja was wollte ich sagen ich habe jetzt die telekom ja gekündigt
und am nächsten monat habe ich dann nur noch unity media für für fernseh internet und
für telefon habe ich bin ich dann habe ich die rufnummer zu einem wald anbieter portieren
lassen das heißt ich bin jetzt mit der orts orts telefonnummer komplett unabhängig von
irgendwelchen anbietern das ist eigentlich ja der friseur das filmt auch ab und zu mal
das hört sich sehr unharmonisch an irgendwie fest sind so mein 2k19 ja ich benutze es ja
auch nicht internet in deutschland sagt ja ist ja auch so das habe ich ich weiß das
habe ich schon vor jahren gesagt in videos das sage ich immer noch wie kann in traceroute
eigentlich die zeiten unterschiedlich sein zum server direkt 8 ms zu den routern dazwischen
mehr bin ich jetzt auch nicht so ganz sicher ich denke mal es liegt daran weil das hier
ja nicht wirklich ein paket ist was von a nach b durchgeht sondern das ist ein paket
das ist 1 das das das das das das das das das und das hat halt mal 108 millisekunden
gedauert und man darf nicht vergessen hier muss der router ja eine custom custom fehlermeldung
für dich generieren und vielleicht sind die dinger gerade besonders beansprucht und haben
einfach kein bock drauf und das ist ganz niedrig priorisiert könnte ja sein so leute
also ihr habt ja schon am am titel vom stream jetzt gesehen das ist heute es gibt kein spezielles
thema das einzige thema was ich mir überlegt habe was wir ausprobieren können wenn es
nicht genug anderes zeug zum schwätzen und gucken einfällt wir können mal wireguard
vpn ausprobieren das habe ich ja schon gesagt dass ich das mal seit einer weile ausprobieren
will mal zu installieren unter linux und zu gucken wie man das einrichtet das könnten
wir machen ich habe hier den den den raspberry noch liegen oder ich habe theoretisch sogar
zwei raspberries dafür noch liegen auf dem einen könnten wir mal einen wireguard server
installieren und dann ein vpn in den aufbauen und gucken ob das funktioniert ansonsten mache
ich jetzt mal hier bist du krank ja bin ich ach so das von gestern noch alles von gestern
glaube das kann ich alles löschen erst mal zwei wochen krank schreiben lassen ich war
jetzt die woche krank geschrieben das war diesmal auch echt nur ich habe also ich habe
seltener kältung und ich habe seltener kältung wo ich tatsächlich mal drei tage im bett
liegen normalerweise geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut dann liege ich mal einen tag und
dann ist wieder ok ja das würde ich machen also ich würde erst mal kontrollieren dass
die netzwerkprobleme auf jeden fall nicht bei dir lokal liegen ja du kannst zum beispiel
jetzt mal kurz schreiben wie das bei dir daheim aufgebaut ist also wenn das so was ganz simples
ist wie dein desktop rechner an der fritzbox und dann direkt ins internet da kann ja eigentlich
nicht allzu viel allzu viel passieren zwischendurch und ein bisschen gaming traffic routen kriegt
eine fritzbox auch hin ich halte die fritzbox nicht für einen super geilen router oder
für für für ein tolles netzwerkgerät an sich aber das kriegt sie hin und die fritzbox
ist ein super multifunktionsgerät das auf jeden fall der eigentliche netzwerk part kommt
halt bei der fritzbox ein bisschen kurz aber es ist halt auch ein noobgerät letztendlich
also das fritzbox soll halt jeder verwenden können da haben sie halt noch ein paar funktionen
die normale user nicht so brauchen wie irgendwelche wlans oder mehrere sslds oder sowas haben
sie halt verzichtet drauf oder halt sehr rudimentär implementiert
das ist was für ein stream ok
das ist ein guter tweet das ist ein echt guter tweet weil allgenom wir wollen das windows
unserer pc's und notebooks mit bloatware misshandeln was gehört auf jeden fall dazu also wenn man
windows wirklich verploaten will was auf jeden fall dazu gehört ist ein virenscanner
ohne virenscanner kein bloat am besten noch irgendwie norton antivirus internet security
suite 2019 premium edition dann hast du dann erstmal 2 gigabyte was definitiv McAfee ok
ist der typ nicht im knast oder war das ein anderer
war der nicht im jail
ne ne doch nicht das war ein anderer ok keine ahnung
was auch wichtig ist die ganzen diese ganzen pay to win diese ganzen komischen spiele
die windows schon standardmäßig installiert hier oder mittlerweile nicht mehr candy crush
und alle zig games die so ähnlich aussehen dann braucht man noch irgendwelche tune up
utilities 2019
was bräuchte was bräuchte man sonst noch leute was was sagt der chat registry cleaner
ja den registry cleaner muss auch unbedingt drauf
office demo gibt es mittlerweile auch noch office demo office 300 demo was gibt es noch
gar nicht mehr oder doch office 365 test
ja das muss auch drauf
tune up ja tune up muss sein ey
team viewer für den support ja
bescheuerte antwort das ist nichts zum installieren
ich muss mal meine fragen jetzt echt aufräumen
das funktioniert nicht so ganz oder ich klick das unterste an und dann kommt da eben was
ganz merkwürdiges
ich glaube mein tool ist kaputt oder
ich mein jetzt hier steht ja was usb und hier steht wasim und jetzt klick ich das weg
und jetzt kommt auf einmal da unten was neues
ich glaube das ist verpackt 1754 jetzt müsste 1802 darin stehen
was ich glaube mein tool ist nicht nicht so ganz richtig
das funktioniert anscheinend oder
ja das war irgendwie verpackt
wie wärs eigentlich mal wenn du dir eine grafikkarte programmierst
ich hab letztens ein video gesehen wo einer angefangen hat eine grafikkarte zu bauen
also sehr rudimentär mit vga
das ging das ging 45 minuten wo er halt die ganze schaltung zusammengebaut hat für horizontal
und verticalsync und zeug was man halt so braucht
und im zweiten video hat er gesagt macht er dann die rgb ausgabe
der ram downloader ja den braucht man auch noch
von ben eater ja ich glaub das war der
welche switch spiele kannst du empfehlen ich hab nur
3 ich hab mario kart ich hab mario galaxy und ich äh nicht galaxy mario odyssey und
ja sag dir dir ach ist es da wo du wo du deine ausbildung
anfängst nee hab ich nix von gesagt bin gar nix
kennst du einen guten simplen fax server es ist 2019
fax kein schimmer
keine ahnung wirklich nicht kein schimmer gut fax aber
ähm warum warum brauchen wir denn fax aber 2019
gut äh nee kann ich dir leider kein empfehlen weiß ich nicht
asteris kann das bestimmt es kann alles aber das ist nicht simpel
kein schimmer was ein guter fax server ist
ein clear all button ja ein clear all button wäre wirklich nicht verkehrt einzubauen
machen wir den hin machen wir hier am besten clear all button
hin oben ha um in um links in die eck
oh man ey guck mal ob da
oben eine navigationsleiste hin machen aber brauch ich nicht
machen da oben jetzt nen button
na da oben ist jetzt ein delete button fertig
und eventuell mit refresh button oh jetzt wirds aber advance da
das ding refreshed automatisch es sei denn ich stells auf refresh null
wie gesagt ich bin heute ziemlich planlos was stream angeht
ich hab einfach angemacht ich hab nicht spezielles vor oder sowas
ihr müsst mir jetzt entweder entweder machen wir jetzt wireguard vpn
oder ihr müsst mich noch mit irgendwelchen sachen zuknallen wo ich was zu erzählen kann
oder zu zeigen kann hab ich irgendwas übersehen vielleicht
achja stimmt mario maker 2 wollte ich mir auch holen
auf jeden fall ich hab meine switch auf jeden fall mehr angehabt als xbox one und ps4 zusammen
die hab ich ja quasi gar nicht angehabt die switch hatte ich immerhin für press of
the wild an wie dann braucht man da so bis man da halbwegs beim endgegner ist wenn man
sich die welt anguckt wahrscheinlich so 20 20 30 stunden
dann mario odyssey nochmal so würd ich sagen so 15 stunden oder nee nicht ganz 10 stunden
ich hab ja nicht alle alle sterne gemacht oder am mond oder
ja und mario kart auch nicht so lange aber auf jeden fall würd ich sagen schonmal so
50 60 stunden hatte ich wenigstens die switch an im vergleich zu xbox one und ps4 die hatte
ich zusammen vielleicht 5 stunden an oder so das ist eigentlich voll der witz was man
sich mal überlegt ja ich würd sagen wir gucken uns das jetzt
einfach mit war ja gar mal an war ja gar nicht so der neueste schrei was was vpn angeht
ich hab noch überhaupt nichts mitgemacht warum war ja gar noch nicht open vpn weil
ich ja open vpn kenne ich schon war ja gar nicht noch nicht es geht einfach darum dass
ich mir mal angucken kann ich will es nicht verwenden ich will es mir einfach mal gucken
wir könnten uns jetzt natürlich ne wir könnten uns jetzt irgendwie bei digital ocean oder
so ne vm machen zu der wir uns connecten allerdings ist glaube ich keine so gute idee öffentlich
das ganze zu machen dann hab ich sofort sofort die chinesen im vpn
meinst du dass die wenigsten spiele dich mittlerweile noch flaschen weil man mittlerweile einfach
alles gesehen hat also ich denke das spielt auf jeden fall mit rein dass man mit vielen
sachen nicht mehr so begeistert werden kann wie am anfang ich glaube dass wo man das am
schönsten sieht ist weil man mal eine call of duty singleplayer kampagne spielt
4 5 mw 2 black ops 1 hat mich voll gefesselt die singleplayer kampagne obwohl es im prinzip
der gleiche lineare blödsinn ist wie die anderen spieler auch aber irgendwann habe
ich überhaupt keinen spaß mehr dran gehabt und ich glaube gar nicht mal weil es so viel
schlechter war die city kampagnen danach sondern weil es wirklich immer mehr vom gleichen
ist zum 50. mal in den heli abschießen wurde wo der raketenwerfer davor gesportet ist und
sowas also ich denke das spielt schon mit rein aber ich glaube das hauptsächliche problem
ist einfach dass es den spielen zum größten teil irgendwie an substanz fehlt zumindest
die großen titeln und man auch gar kein bock hat sich irgendwie großartig noch einzuarbeiten
hat man mit war ja gerade auch den ping of glory von der telekom zum teufel ist der ping
of glory ich habe keine ahnung was das sein soll hallo zugucker das problem ist das für
altfern ich glaube das liegt gar nicht mal so sehr da dran kennst du das twitter ad nicht
ne ping of glory vor der was da komme ich jetzt wahrscheinlich bei einer porn seite
raus so teufel ist der telekom los ok moment wie siehst du progamer sichert euch den ping
of glory für eure progamer karriere zum telekom was die gesellschaft denkt was meine freunde
denken was wie ich mich fühle was ich wirklich war das ist auch noch schlecht gemehmt das
ist auch noch das ist auch nicht war gut oh man gerne verlegt uns die glasfaser es ist
eh übelster cringe teilweise wenn man sich das anguckt teilweise die werbung auf youtube
von manchen firmen oder manche tweets oder auf twitter irgendwelche ads wo wo irgendwelche
firmen versuchen so im trend der zeit zu sein es gibt ganz wenige anzeigen wo ich bedenke
ihr habt das ihr habt das internet so ungefähr halbwegs gut nachgemacht die meisten sachen
wirken einfach übelst übelst cringe so wo du denkst da saß irgendein marketing typ
drinne der hat sich 300 mien bildchen angeguckt und versucht was draus zu stricken was irgendwie
auf sie passt und lustig ist ohne den eigentlichen sinn dahinter verstanden zu haben also ihr
wisst was ich meine man kann ja nicht wirklich von sinn sprechen aber ohne ohne so die gedanken
dahinter verstanden zu haben und dann ist das echt das ist so wie wenn du in irgendwelchen
fernsehsendungen früher so so jugendsprache gesehen hast die irgendwie zehn jahre zu früh
war das ist aber voll krass alter oder irgendwie so was das sagt auch keine sau mehr wahrscheinlich
ist bruder muss los noch nicht mal mehr angesagt heute wahrscheinlich sagst du heute wieder
aber kannst du was muss ich das das kriegst ja nur so richtig mit wenn du da wenn du da
auch dabei bist und dementsprechend wirkt es auch immer so zu ultra cringe wenn das
irgendwelche marketing läden versuchen
voll krass genau das hat man das hat man vor vor 35 40 23 30 jahre hat man das gesagt
heute fährste pedalo ne wie heißen die dinge weiß ich nicht so pedalo ja genau ok mein
raspberry wo ist er denn ja komm mal her raspberry komm mal her nicht den anderen scheiß runterspeisen
ich hab den hier sehr abenteuerlich platziert ich muss nämlich mal den raspberry holen
und die sd karte raus machen sd karte kartenleser wir machen da nämlich ein neues raspian drauf
weil der kram hat mittlerweile so viele updates gekriegt seitdem wir das das letzte mal gemacht
haben wahrscheinlich sind wir mit einer neuen installation besser dran ist das halo ne fängt
an wie halo oder ja jetzt nicht mehr
halt mal muss jetzt einmal muss jetzt einmal sein zu leise das ist ja das richtige 2000
so wir brauchen buster light moment das was ich gerade gelöscht hab ist das ist das gleiche
wie was es zum download gibt fail da kann ich euch jetzt mal was cooles zeigen ich hab
das ja gerade gelöscht hier und normalerweise ist es weg aber ich hab mein rm gealliast
auf auf nen papierkorb jetzt kann ich nämlich einfach sagen trash restore feil nummer null
und zack da ist es wieder das ist mal pock oder ich weiß nicht der kommando zeilen papierkorb
das ist massive big brain 900 iq plays gut wenn sich da nichts geupdatet hat dann brauchen
wir auch ein raspian nicht neu zu installieren sondern können einfach den raspian mal direkt
ans netzwerkabel und in strom pappen ich schmeiß hier echt die hälfte ich hab hier ich hab
hier neben mir die zwei rechner stehen der zu spiele rechner und den den anderen jetzt
ich vorschau streaming rechner und ich hab da mittlerweile so viele kartons und dinger
und zeug drauf muss ich aufpassen nicht alles runterschmeißen wenn ich den raspian drunter
rausziehe so lips und nu brauchen wir chrome versorgung für das ding ob wir den einfach
an usb vom rechner anschließen sollten ach nee wir fuck das ding braucht ja wieder usbc
ich habe gar kein usbc da wo habe ich wo habe ich in usbc so scheiße meine china kabel
sind noch nicht da ich hatte ich hatte mir einen ich hatte mir doch hier die usb kabel
bestellt ich habe andere bestellt als die die wir uns im stream angeguckt haben ich
habe bestellt 2 in 1 wartet mal ich zeig euch mal ja allerdings 50 stück
ja also im prinzip mehr oder weniger die hier bloß 50 bloß 50 keine keine 100 also
hier die die micro usb auf usbc übrigens die bilder sind immer übelst schlecht freigestellt
in dem fall geht man kommt half life 3 nach episode 3 die halo 3 also die halo musik an
sich ist wirklich ziemlich nice wieso brauchst du so viele ich brauche eigentlich nicht
so viele ich habe bloß kein bock immer usb kabel zu suchen deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich bestelle mir jetzt einfach mal 50 usb kabel dann ist ruhe weil jetzt habe ich ja
gerade wieder das problem wo habe ich den usbc kabel wo habe ich den usbc kabel wo habe
ich den usbc kabel das ist echt ich habe nicht viele usbc kabel ich habe welche aber
ich weiß nicht warum bc wo habe ich in den usbc kabel ja ich brauche usbc kabel sonst
kann ich den raspberry 4 nicht anschließen warte mal kurz ich gucke mal in meine usb
kiste ob da ist ob da was drin ist
es ist alles wirklich usb
das ist alles micro usb wo habe ich ihn hier in usbc kabel das ist jetzt ja voll wieder
super super nice vorbereitung ich weiß wo habe ich ihn in usbc kabel
ich habe es da ist es
das ist wirklich praktisch ich habe es gefunden so angestöpselt ist es schließen wir den
raspberry mal an ob der ist falsch rum richtig rum achtung
er ist dran und leuchtet aber dann sollte das auch funktionieren
dann connecten wir uns da mal per ssh drauf auf das ding ich hoffe mal das kriegt die
gleiche ip wie das letzte mal wenn nicht muss ich in den router gucken was der cp dem
ding da ist er doch ich glaube ich hatte auch keinen kein custom name gegeben das passt
schon und wir machen erstmal update da dürfte es ja ein paar updates gegeben haben jetzt
habe ich auch nie gesehen was was möchte mir das jetzt sagen
ja einfach immer immer ja drücken wir waren mal bei einem bei einem china laden und wir
haben die bedienung absolut nicht verstanden also in frankfurt gibt es ja jede menge china
lehen und wir haben es wirklich nicht gecheckt und auf einmal sagt die bedienung so auf ganz
schlecht im deutsch einfach sagen ja oder einfach immer sagen ja so nach dem motto wir
sollen gar nicht mit ihr lange diskutieren sondern wenn sie was sagt soll wir einfach
sagen ja und das machen wir seitdem auch immer wenn wir in den laden reingehen und man muss
sagen das funktioniert wirklich gut man das ist so die folgt die folgt except einfach
micharo das usb c kabel ist wirklich ein problem weil das ist so noch nicht so extrem verbreitet
dass man davon so viel rumfliegen hat für micro usb aber dafür wird es in zukunft ordentlich
verbreitet sein und ich habe jetzt ja vorgesorgt wenn die chinesen endlich liefern
hat man nämlich 50 micro usb kabel mit usb c adapter gekauft dann ist endlich ein für
allemal usb knappheit erledigt und wenn man sich das mal anschaut das ist eigentlich übelst
billig und es gibt die gibt übrigens noch günstiger das ist einer der bisschen teureren
anbieter aber ich habe wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt das sind 100 usb kabel mit adapter
inklusive versand mit dhl für 85 euro das sind das sind quasi 75 cent 85 cent für
das usb kabel also jetzt bei 100 das ist also dafür kannst du gar keine super geile qualität
kriegen aber macht nichts so lange solange die dinger solange die dinger geräte mit
strom versorgen ist ok ich genau wir drop schippen die einfach zu zu zu leuten aber das
ist nicht sind nicht genau die die ich mir geholt habe 100 stück ne das sind andere
ist immer leute ich gucke mal gerade im zweiten rechner in meine mails weil ich zeige euch
mal welche das sind und wenn und wenn die ankommt dann probieren wir die auch mal aus
ob das funktioniert
aliexpress aliexpress aliexpress your order has been shipped am neunten siebten also sind
schon ein bisschen dir max bla bla bla your order has been shipped ja und wo steht was
ich geordert habe man was 200 pieces nee moment fuck nein ich habe keine 200 pieces bestellt
ich habe ich habe damit kein problem wenn die chinesen jetzt 200 schicken aber ich habe
doch keine 200 stück bestellt moment das muss ich jetzt gar mal überprüfen wo ist
meine aliexpress aber wo ist meine aliexpress bestätigung message vom aliexpress bla wo
ist meine wo ist meine auftrass bestätigung aliexpress sie wollen 200 max sagt ja ja moment
was meine auftrass bestätigung ich habe keine ich habe nur eine message your order has been
shipped your order has been shipped und zwar als das andere kann die kann die kann die
china mal nicht richtig anzeigen ich hoffe ich habe keine 200 bestellt da bin ich mir
ganz sicher ach scheiß drauf egal ich habe keine 200 ich weiß genau dass ich 50 bestellt
habe weil 200 war wirklich ein bisschen viel und ich habe es halt nur sehr die können
mir ruhig 200 schicken wenn es wenn es auch nur 53 euro kostet oder fertig geupdated
ob grade muss muss man das hier einstamm machen ich glaube das geht mittlerweile alles in einem
wird eigentlich normalerweise wird das hier nicht empfohlen wird das bei einem vierer
noch empfohlen soll man das bei einem vierer machen weiß das jemand gab es da irgendwelche
patches dass man dass man den vierer mal richtig updaten soll hier auf firmen wir und alles
normalerweise soll man davon ja die finger weglassen ja also warm wurde das ding als
wir es getestet haben ordentlich hier war es komische artikel ich glaube wir upgraden
einfach mal nicht wir lassen das ding jetzt so ich mein für für wire guard ist ja noch
wirklich krei hat ding na ok wie funktioniert es jetzt wire guard respiren der bachmann
laden alter hat hier raspberry pie wire guard das sogar halbwegs aktueller artikel ja steckstoff
kühlung von raspberry wenn ich habe ja aktuell ja so denn so denn so ein ganz normalen passiv
kühler drauf und das ding ist jetzt einfach nur an und ich lege mal die hand drauf und
das das ist schon so warm der macht nichts der eidl einfach nur rum man sieht hier das
ding macht nichts außer eidl sein das ist schon so warm dass du den finger nicht drauf
liegen lassen kannst ich solls von klimaanlage durchzug anmachen also nicht klimaanlage an
sondern einfach nur den die belüftung anmachen die katze guckt hat sie kommt kritisch vom
schrank jetzt auf die klimaanlage schicko nichts schlimmes schlimmes die katze ist kritisch
mit der klimaanlage die kommt nicht so erfreut gut ist nichts schlimmes ohje jetzt habe ich
sie jetzt habe ich sie jetzt habe ich sie verwirrt ok als aufbau der raspberry pie blablabla
vpn als ok clients als road warrior wir machen die verbindung machen wir dann vom gut ok
wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch ein zweites netz für das vpn sonst funktioniert sich richtig
die kriege ich maus support mit i3 hin maus anschließen das ist von haus aus also da
musst du nichts machen wenn der x aber deine maus erkennt ist gut dann geht das einfach
was machst du das mit den subs vielleicht mache ich direkt nach dem stream heute ok
war ja gar installation auf dem raspberry pie gibt es denn ab search war ja gar gibt
es das denn schon vielleicht mittlerweile in den repos drinnen nein
kommt man dazu gar eine anleitung für basta lan alter der ist aber schon eine ganz schön
aktuell erst mal kindle headers installieren ok kindle headers kann nie schaden wahrscheinlich
muss er zeug kompilieren ja ja i3 hat immer maus support also brauchst gar nichts wenn
x aber deine maus erkennt dann ist gut macht der jetzt moment was macht er da der aktiviert
das debian unstable repo und dann edit keys von ubuntu ich weiß nicht genau was er da
macht ehrlich gesagt aber er edit neue repos edit neue keys zum wo wahrscheinlich pakete
signiert sind dann stellt er ab irgendwie so ein dass das die pakete irgendwie kein
priorität haben oder sowas das sieht mir unnötig kompliziert aus gibt es nicht einfach
ein ordentliches depot mit war ja gar drinnen stimmt stimmt sorry nicht ubuntu ich kann
tun genau ok wenn die ok wenn die offizielle debian pakete also wenn die offizielle debian
anleitung schon sagt man soll das machen dann machen wir das auch machen einfach mal was
der tut hier treibt ich meine es ist ja nicht schlimm wenn es kaputt geht wir können einfach
neu installieren und gut ist ok warum muss ich den ubuntu key n nochmal das lasse ich
mal weg und warum soll ich den ubuntu key adden das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn das
kommt auch später wir machen es auch nicht wie er das schreibt sondern wir machen das
so wie die debian leute das schreiben update ok ja man muss das doch machen
da will wohl eine netze kommen ich will einfach mal wirecard wirecard wireshark nein wireguard
ausprobieren wir brauchen wir müssen dem ding aber wirklich ein eigenes netz geben
mal gucken wie das funktioniert ja das stimmt ich denke das ist aber echt so ich denke mir
bei vielen tutorials immer so ach nee ey was die da schreiben kann überhaupt nicht sein
und am ende stelle ich dann fest ach nee es hätte doch so sein müssen soll mal gucken
ob der jetzt auch so klar und nicht ok er will er will nicht upgraden das schon mal
gut install wireguard wireguard yes oh yes kennt noch einer wie ist das ahmed ahmed
der terrorist das war mal vor so ein paar jahren das ist so so ein bauchredner typ das
eingesagt fand ich übelst lustig damals die die neu auflagen davon die er gebracht hat
war nicht mehr so witzig aber die die ersten das der erste also das original und die das
erste weihnachtsspecial fand ich übelst lustig silence genau richtig aus serious max was
was hat er denn geschrieben ich hab das gar nicht gesehen der gaylover hat er porn links
gespammt oder was bei dem namen erst mal ripp ok wir müssen keine module bauen wie es aussieht
jeets haben ich hab sie überhaupt nicht gesehen dass ich also ich hab jetzt auch nichts schlimmes
im chat gesehen ehrlich gesagt aber ich vertraue da mal meinen mod so weit dass ich sehe auch
nicht alles do you know da wey das fand ich nie lustig ich weiß gar nicht warum das warum
diese ugana knuckles geschichte so abgegangen ist ich fand ugana knuckles übelst lustig
genauso wie wie fand zulullen oder jeder typ heißt aber auch da sieht man mal wieder auch
dass nicht jeder twitch humor was für mich ist
kennst du who killed captain alex nähe
ja raspberries sind immer wahnsinnig schnell wenn es um sowas geht wir gucken mal wir gucken
mal wie wie sehr die also wollte gerade sagen wie sehr die cpu ausgelastet ist aber anscheinend
hat sich schon erledigt
dass wir mal hin eben so einen top laufen oder machen wir hier oben weiter microsoft
allerdings könnte man könnte man eigentlich auch wie reboot ist immerhin die zeit haben
aber ja tastatur tapping asmr hier so ist neu gestartet was ich ja wo wir gerade bei
sachen sind ich nicht lustig fandet sachen die übelst lustig fand und die nie so groß
rausgekommen sind aber die waren die waren einfach ihrer zeit voraus sind sind die videos
von mega 64 die sind so lustig steht da die die videos also nicht alle sondern die wo
sie die gehen wo sie die games nachmachen die sind so lustig aber die waren einfach
ihrer die waren ihrer zeit voraus ja die gab es schon zu zeiten wo es youtube noch nicht
gefunden und ich gab moment haben die haben die playlists
nehmen wir was was richtiges resident evil 4 genau
das ist übelst lustig gewesen vor 13 das ist übelst alt das ist das ist mega lustig
aber das problem ist die waren ihrer zeit voraus hätten die das heute wenn die heute
die videos machen die hätten fünf millionen abos
der auflösung geht nicht
um
Was verkaufst du?
Nichts hier.
Bist du eine Pizza?
Ja.
Ich kaufe sie auf einem hohen Preis.
Was ist dein Name?
Stranger.
Ich kaufe sie auf einem hohen Preis.
Das hier?
Danke.
Was kaufst du?
Was verkaufst du?
Nichts.
Was kaufst du?
Was verkaufst du?
Soll ich hier noch stehen und was machen oder sollten wir irgendwo hin?
Ich bin schon da.
Oh wirklich?
Komm zurück ins Auto.
Ich bin schon da.
Let's go!
Ich finde das...
Die hatten damals...
Wie heißt der? Miyamoto hatten sie mal dabei in einem Video.
Aber das ist halt auch uralt.
Kojima hatten sie in einem Video mal mit dabei.
Das war alles noch vor YouTube.
Das fand ich halt übelst lustig.
Die waren zu früh.
Würden sie heute solche Videos machen,
würde das übelst abgehen.
Und vor allem hätte es ein bisschen höhere Quali.
Wir haben den Kram schon installiert.
Okay, LS Mod.
Guck mal ob da irgendwas mit WireGuard drin ist.
Sollte da jetzt nicht was von WireGuard drin ist stehen?
Nein nicht.
Das Mod ist schon richtig.
Okay, steht nicht drin.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Kannst du was über endliche Zustandsmaschinen erzählen?
Nein, kann er nicht.
Das ist zu viel Theorie.
Die haben halt auch Tetris gemacht.
Assassin's Creed ist auch übelst lustig von denen.
Wo sie über so einen Markt laufen und sich versuchen zu verstecken und so.
Den Pi neu starten?
Nein, nein, den muss man nicht neu starten.
Man kann auch einfach sagen System...
Nee, Sys...
Wie war es?
Sysctl-p?
Genau, fertig, müssen ihn neu starten.
Ich kann Immunetabaku, ich kann solche theoretischen Sachen aus dem Handgelenk nicht rausschütteln.
Keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Okay, wie funktioniert das her zweit?
Ist die Musik an oder ist die einfach nur leise?
Ist einfach nur leise.
Weiß jemand, bei welchem VM-Tool man diese Menüleisten deaktivieren kann?
Oder brauche ich da die Paid-Version?
Meinst du die hier?
Einfach was zu machen kannst, du kannst Exclusive-Mode machen, dann kommt die Leiste nicht mehr.
Wie hieß das Video nochmal?
So war Mega64.
Da gibt es eine Playlist, wo sie alle ihre Social Experiments oder wie das heißt drin haben.
Die Erstellung der Keys wird im Verzeichnen EDC Bayergaard durchgeführt.
Um sicherzustellen, dass alle da eine richtige Berechtigung setzen.
You must auf 077.
Das lassen wir mal.
Ich mache meine Keys doch nicht auf 077.
Ach Moment, das ist UMAS, das ist umgedreht.
Das bedeutet, es kriegt 7-0-0.
Geht das beim Workstation-Player auch?
Wahrscheinlich.
Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus.
Okay, Keys generieren.
WG, Gen-Key.
WG, Private-Key.
Okay, machen wir das mal.
Also WG ist wahrscheinlich das Kommando für Wire-Key.
WG, Gen-Key.
WG, Private-Key.
Okay, machen wir das mal.
Also WG ist wahrscheinlich das Kommando für Wire-Key.
WG ist wahrscheinlich das Kommando für Wire-Guard.
Keys generieren.
Dann Pipen nach T.
T splittet das auf.
In der Datei und...
Also T sorgt dafür, dass das, was du an Text
quasi in den Befehl reinpipest,
wird einmal in die Datei umgeleitet
und einmal Standard-Auth wieder rausgeschrieben.
Und danach macht er das Pub-Key.
Okay, der erstellt zwei Key-Files.
Server-Public-Key und Server-Private-Key.
Passt das jetzt schon?
Hey, easy.
Okay, wahrscheinlich brauchen sie 7.0.0 als Keys.
Alle Key-Files brauchen in der Regel
zumindest mal 0.0
bei Krupp und others.
Mark zu Singleton.
Nur Whisky.
Klassen eher nicht.
Klein-Keys generieren.
Moment, das muss ich auf meinem Client jetzt machen.
Nee, Moment.
Ach nee, ah, nee, nee.
Das sind die Keys, die ich für zukünftige
Clients generiere, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Okay.
Sollen wir das jetzt auch in dem Verzeichnis machen?
Klein-1-Pub-Key.
Server-Configuration.
Dazu wird die Datei
mit WG0 angelegt.
Warum muss es denn WG0 sein?
Ach, das Interface
heißt wahrscheinlich später WG0.
Okay, wir Copy-Paste das jetzt einfach mal.
IP-Tables, wir machen überhaupt keine
IP-Tables-Regel.
Wir lassen einfach alles offen.
Ach, da sind IP-Tables-Regeln.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Private-Key.
Hinzufügen.
Den zweiten Client haben wir noch nicht.
Wir haben nur Klein-1.
Klein-1 ist der Stop-PC.
Klein-1-Public-Key hinzufügen.
Soll ich da den,
soll man da jetzt das File hinzufügen?
Oder soll man den Key hinzufügen?
Hinzufügen.
Was wird versucht?
Ich versuche gerade WireGuard zu installieren
und zu schauen,
warum alle WireGuard so geil finden.
Benutzst du noch HDDs in deinem System?
Ja.
Für, wenn man viel Speicher braucht.
Ja, was muss man da jetzt machen?
Klein-Public-Key hinzufügen.
Also ich vermute mal, dass man hier wirklich jetzt den
den Key hinzufügen muss.
Und dort
den Private-Key vom Server.
Aber das im Klartext in den Konfig zu schreiben,
ist doch irgendwie, irgendwie wir.
Warum macht man nicht einfach das
File dahin?
Oder muss da wirklich, oder muss,
nee, da muss das File hin.
Klein-1.
Klein-1-Public-Key.
Das muss, das muss dahin.
Alles andere wäre total beknackt.
So, also aber Private-Key.
So.
Ok.
So, mal Konfiguration, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Klein-Konfiguration.
Für jeden Klein erstelle ich
eine Konfig-Datei. Klein-1-Konfig.
Hä?
Der hat das doch hier oben schon erstellt.
Warum erstellt er das hier unten dann noch einmal?
Wollen wir das jetzt verstehen?
Ich überspringe das erst mal.
WireGuard starten.
WG-quick-up-WG0.
Ok, gucken wir mal, ob das überhaupt starten würde.
Äh.
Key is not correct length or format.
So, aber Private-Key.
Ok, dann muss man da wirklich den Key eintragen.
Sehe ich das richtig, ja?
Also, man muss da wirklich, ähm.
Ok.
Tragen wir mal da den Key ein.
Jetzt erst mal hier, Leute.
Gleich mal Server-Key leaked.
Sauber-Key leaked.
Warum muss man das da im Klartext reinschreiben?
Das ist doch ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Wozu?
Ok, das war's anscheinend.
So, jetzt läuft WireGuard.
Mir WG.
Ach, da können wir auch mal hier bei ModWG suchen.
Äh.
Ok, jetzt läuft der Kram anscheinend.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt hier auch einen Port offen.
Der.
Der da.
Glaub ich, der WireGuard-Port.
51820.
Ja, das ist der WireGuard-Port.
Ok.
Gut, die Config war jetzt relativ simpel.
Ich verstehe zwar immer noch nicht, warum man die Keys im Klartext reinschreiben muss und nicht die Files.
Aber gut.
Ja, warum nicht?
So, ähm.
WireGuard-Status einfach WG.
Ok, also wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist unsere IP-Range für.
Genau, unser Netz für WireGuard VPN ist 101010.
1.
Also quasi 1 bis 254.
Import.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt auf meinem Client installiere.
Können wir mal machen.
Hier WireGuard.
Den Kram installieren.
Wobei, mal gucken.
Ob man noch auf dem Server was anderes machen muss.
Firewall-Config lassen wir mal komplett außen vor.
Der offizielle Android-Client.
Windows.
Komm, wir probieren den Windows-Client aus.
Das ist die.
Wenn der Windows-Client funktioniert, funktionieren alle anderen Clients wahrscheinlich auch.
Alles gut, ja.
Wie es geht mit dem Friseur, geht es gut.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen-Friseur.
Ähm.
Dann findest du den Stream von Fabian.
Du bist aber mutig.
Nee, ich mach das in der Windows-VM.
In der Windows-VM installieren wir das jetzt.
Dafür haben wir doch die 33 Milliarden VMs.
Das ist der falsche Befehl.
Gebaidet.
Nee, wie ist das?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen.
Das haben wir doch als Befehl drinne.
Ah.
Ausrufezeichen-Fabian.
Das ist okay.
Okay.
Gibt es das schon im Windows-Store?
WireGuard.
Was zum Teufel hat der Scheiß mit WireGuard zu tun?
A Guide to Becoming a Photoshop Wizard.
Klingt voll nach WireGuard.
Gebaidet.
Okay, Windows-Client.
Wo ist der Windows-Client?
Windows-Client.
Ah, WireGuard kommt install.
Windows.
Gebaidet.
Was muss man dann machen?
Import Tunnel-Files.
Ah, die Klein-Config muss ich dann importieren.
Aha.
Dann erzeugen wir jetzt mal die Klein-Config würde ich sagen.
Weil die Klein-Config haben wir, soweit ich das jetzt gesehen habe,
haben wir die noch gar nicht erzeugt.
Ihr Klein-Config.
Ach, deswegen muss man das doppelt machen.
Das ist die Server-Config und das ist nicht die Config,
die der Server braucht für den Client.
Das ist die Config, die man später auf dem Client einfügt.
Ah, so.
Easy as a fuck.
Würde ich das sagen?
Ah, so.
Client-Config.
Zack.
Copy-Paste.
Endpoint.
Was hat man Raspberry für eine IP?
Geh weg.
Ähm.
Ups.
Ich hätte es vielleicht mal speichern sollen.
Was hat man Raspberry für eine IP?
Ah.
Was soll das überhaupt werden, wenn es fertig ist?
Ein WireGuard VPN.
Ein WireGuard VPN und ich versuche herauszukriegen,
warum alle WireGuard VPN so geil finden.
Endpoint.
Ah, hier. So, das da.
Alle IPs.
Naja, das ist ziemlich doppelt gemoppelt, oder?
Ich meine, ich muss nicht alle IPs eintragen und eine einzelne IP.
Das ist ziemlich doppelt, ne?
Server-Public Key hinzufügen.
Server-Public Key ist der da?
WireGuard VPN.
Habe ich noch nichts mit gemacht bisher.
Client-One-Private-Key hinzufügen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen merkwürdig,
dass die so viel mit Keys in Config-Files hantieren,
anstatt einfach ein Config-File und ein Key-File zu nehmen,
was man zusammen in Zip packt oder so.
DNS.
DNS ist, Google, wenn schon.
Nee, DNS nehmen wir mal meinen internen.
Mein interner ist, nicht, dass ich das Mist erzähle.
Ich glaube, der.
Okay, das heißt doch jetzt,
diese Datei brauche ich auf Windows.
Diese Datei brauche ich auf meine Windows
und importiere es in den Windows WireGuard Klein.
Und dann sollte alles funktionieren.
Und wenn das wirklich alles ist,
was man machen muss,
dann kann ich verstehen, dass die Leute
WireGuard VPN so nice finden.
Weil das ist im Vergleich zu OpenVPN
ja nun wirklich der Witz an Setup.
Nein.
Aber trotzdem.
Config-File, Spam, Add, Desktop.
Ach, das ist ja Windows.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Manchmal geht mir Windows echt auf den Sack mit sowas.
Options.
Display.
Display-File-Extensions.
Irgendwo hier steht das doch.
Siehts jemand?
Ach, hier oder da.
Windows, ey.
Warum?
Warum macht es mir Windows immer so schwer?
Da ist es.
Activate.
Das war's?
Alter, das ist super easy.
Das ist super easy.
Das ist super einfach.
Das ist wirklich.
Moment Leute.
Das ist eindeutig easy.
Das kann jeder.
Also das kann wirklich jeder.
Cute Chat, genau.
Cute AF Chat.
Und das Ganze dann sogar noch mit einem QR-Code für Android.
Wollen wir das mal probieren?
Also ich hab jetzt leider kein Android-Gerät da, was ich irgendwie streamen kann.
Aber wir können mal das Generieren von dem QR-Code probieren.
Und ich kann das machen, das war aber eh nicht von außen erreichbar.
Das ist super einfach.
Das hat mich jetzt echt überzeugt.
Ich hoffe das ist auch ordentlich implementiert, dass es sicher ist.
Aber das ist echt geil.
Die Config, ganz ehrlich, dazu hätten wir noch nicht mal diesen Guide hier gebraucht.
Das ist wirklich super simple.
Das sind hier 10 Zeilen Config, ne 8 Zeilen Config.
Die OpenVPN Config ist 10 Mal so lang.
Hat nicht selbst Linus Weigart gelobt, kann schon sein.
Also das macht man einen wirklich durchdachten Eindruck.
Das ist easy as a fuck.
Android VM.
Gibt es mittlerweile ein gescheites Android?
Das probieren wir aus, wenn es das gibt.
Hat jemand Erfahrung damit?
Kennt jemand ein ordentliches Android für was ich in VM installieren kann?
Android Studio.
Ach Moment, das bringt mir ja gar nichts.
Ich kann ja schlecht ein QR Code scannen von der VM aus.
Aber wir generieren mal ein QR Code.
Das muss ich jetzt nochmal ausprobieren.
Ich finde das richtig nice.
Das gefällt mir echt gut.
Jetzt könnt ihr alle meinen VPN scannen und feststellen, dass ihr euch von außen nicht verbinden könnt.
Omega Lul.
Ist Weigart schnell?
Gute Frage.
Wir können es mal von der VM in die VM ausprobieren, aber das ist nicht wirklich aussagekräftig.
Ich will aber mal ausprobieren, was passiert.
Wo ist das Bild?
Das Bild ist noch temporär da.
Ich will jetzt aber echt mal probieren, was passiert, wenn ich das scanne.
Wo habe ich mein Tablet?
Tablet?
Mein Tablet ist hier.
Ich kann jetzt ja mal eine abscannen und gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Einfach den QR Scanner mal dran halten.
Gibt es einen Android für X86?
Das ist ein Gescheites.
Wie was davon gehört.
Stell euer 8.1 in VM wäre.
Welches Image?
Wo ist das Image dafür?
Wo ist das Image?
Moment, das ist VirtualBox.
Wir brauchen VM.
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie vertrauenswürdig der Kram hier ist.
Was?
plissroms.com
Sagt mir jetzt nichts.
Aha.
Ok, nice.
Was ist denn Android?
Ein Open Source OS based on Android.
Das kann man in der VM installieren.
Sind die auf GitHub, dann vertraue ich denen mehr.
Tatsächlich.
Sehr interessant.
Ist das alles ISO?
Download ist kaputt.
Das ist jetzt auch Premiere, habe ich schon nie gemacht.
Android in der VM installiert.
Download please.
Aha.
Jetzt wollen sie erstmal was verkaufen.
PlissOS X86.
Ach fuck.
Only KVM und QEMO emulation is currently supported.
Können wir nicht machen.
Auch immer Workstation würden sie anscheinend nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ok, keine Ahnung.
Es reicht ja schon mal, was wir hier mit Windows ausprobiert haben.
Das ist wirklich super einfach.
Wir können jetzt nochmal gucken, was da so durchgeht durch das VPN.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist von VM zu VM, also Netzwerk Limitierung haben wir hier wahrscheinlich relativ wenig.
Das ist von VM zu VM auf dem gleichen Host.
Wie kann man sich jetzt eigentlich anzeigen lassen?
Wer alles connected ist.
Hier, hier.
Das ist cool, das ist wirklich nice.
Ach Moment.
Das bin ich selber, oder?
Nee.
Ge pingen kann ich das Ganze nicht.
Was hat man Windows client jetzt eigentlich für eine IP?
Hier, Endpoint.
Nee, Moment mal.
Das mit der IP müsste hier irgendwo drin sein.
Das hier bin ich, oder?
Das hier ist ja mein...
Moment, bin verwirrt.
Pockt Windows sich Ping anfragen? Das kann tatsächlich sein, dass es die Windows Firewall ist, die ich will.
Turn off Windows Firewall.
Easy.
So sieht Security aus.
Ah, sehr gute Idee Leute.
Twitch Chat, hilfreich.
Ja, Pockt Chat.
Pockt Chat, das wäre doch auch mal ein nice E-Mode, oder?
Nicht Pockt Chat, Pockt Chat.
Ja, Pockt. Das gibt es bestimmt schon als E-Mode.
Pockt Chat.
Pockt Chat, Twitch client für iOS.
Moment, es gibt einen Twitch client für iOS? Das brauche ich ja offiziell. Twitch client ist scheiße.
Geht nicht mehr.
Pockt Chat ist down.
Das brauche ich.
Das brauche ich. Das geht aber bestimmt nur jailbreaked, oder so.
Nee, es gibt, es gibt, äh...
Gibt es nicht mehr.
Es gibt, es gibt, ja Twitch will das nicht. Es gibt keine alternativen Twitch Apps für iOS.
Und die offizielle Twitch App ist Müll.
Pockt Chat.
Okay, also das ist unser Windows client.
Dann, dann machen wir jetzt mal IP Perf, ähm, IP Perf zwischen...
Zwischen den beiden Systemen, würde ich sagen.
Zwar das Minus S, genau.
Machen wir mal den T-Max auf.
IP Perf, IP Perf Minus S.
Sollen wir nämlich mal schauen, ob das Ding auch richtig lauscht am richtigen Interface.
Äh...
Okay, lauscht, lauscht an allen Interfaces.
Dann brauchen wir jetzt nur noch ein IP Perf auf Windows.
Und dann gucken wir mal, wie schnell das über das VPN ist.
Und gemerkt, das ist jetzt ein bisschen dofer Test.
Es ist gleiche VM auf dem gleichen Host.
Aber wir sollten zumindest schon mal ungefähr abschätzen können, was das Ding an CPU-Last verursacht.
Weil ich meine, es läuft auf dem Raspberry.
Das werden wir nämlich sehen, was da durchgeht.
Wir machen vorher noch mal einen Test von diesem Windows zu dem Raspberry und gucken, was da durchgeht.
Ähm, mal andere Sache.
Wie kann ich einfach und schnell auf einem Ubuntu-Sorber die deutsche Zeite date?
Oder willst du Zeitzone?
Zeitzone machst du mit DPKG reconfigure...
TZ?
Ne, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Kann ich aber gleich sagen.
Achso, mein Internet funktioniert ja hier auf Windows nicht, weil ich ja im VPN drinne bin.
TZ-Data.
So war's. DPKG reconfigure nicht, TZ-TZ-Data.
TZ-Data, das sieht dann so aus.
Europe, Timezone. Siehst du, das ist eigentlich verkehrt. Berlin. Und dann stimmt die Uhrzeit auch.
Ansonsten, wenn du einen NTP-Server brauchst, machst du...
Och, da gibt's den System, SystemD, TimeService.
SystemTime, Time...
Also brauchst du gar kein NTP mehr zu installieren, das ist bei SystemD mittlerweile dabei.
Das ist eigentlich fast alles.
TimeSyncD, genau, das ist mittlerweile bei SystemD eigentlich gefühlt alles dabei.
Time...
Ich weiß den Befehl jetzt gerade nicht dafür.
Da kannst du NTP an- und ausschalten, auf jeden Fall drüber.
So, IPperf. Wir probieren erst mal von dem Windows ohne VPN und gucken, was maximal drüber geht.
Und dann probieren wir es mit VPN und gucken, was dann maximal drüber geht.
It's time to restore your device.
Deactivate VPN.
IPperf 3 für Windows. GIF, please.
Da ist es. Zurquen. Hätte ich ja auch gleich ordentlich...
Ups.
Listening.
Ich get Windows Terminal.
Wobei, wir haben doch hier das gute Terminal, warum machen wir das eigentlich in dem Mist Terminal?
Wir haben doch extra die VM damals installiert, um das neue Windows Terminal zu testen.
Dann, warum machen wir das überhaupt zu kompliziert? Da starten wir unser Ubuntu unter Windows.
Wobei, das ist für einen Performance-Test dumm. Wir machen es so.
IPconfig. Wie sieht man die Windows-IP? Irgendwie so, ne?
65?
Ah, Moment.
Das ist natt.
Ja, das ist ja noch viel besser, wie ich das gemacht habe. Haha. So, als wäre es geplant.
Das Ding steht sogar schon in seinem eigenen Netz.
Ist ja noch viel besser.
Dann machen wir einfach IPperf 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 3.
Ne, äh, wie ging das?
Ist wie das richtige...
Wie ist meine richtige IP hier, vom Raspberry?
Doch, 1, 2, 3.
So kann man eh einfach die IP eingeben.
Ich kann mir so Kram immer aus dem Kopf irgendwie so schlecht merken.
Aber pingen kann ich ihn doch, mein Raspberry, oder?
Äh, wie ging das?
Das war super easy eigentlich.
Cumulus Networks.
Blablabla.
Ach, Minus C.
Minus C für Client.
Man könnte einfach so einstellen, dass Client Default ist, ne?
Okay, also wir haben ungefähr...
Ja gut, sagen wir mal so, Gigabit wäre theoretisches Maximum 125 MB die Sekunde.
Und wir haben ungefähr 85 MB die Sekunde.
Das ist, das ist okay.
Ich mein, das war auch, das deckt sich auch ungefähr mit dem, was wir bei unserem Raspberry-4-Test hatten.
Ich mein, das Ziel ist immer noch ein Raspberry-4, da kann er sich allzu viel.
Also okay.
Ein bisschen weniger, weil ich mein, es ist von VM zu, zu einem Raspberry und sowas.
Ich hab euch übrigens die ganze Zeit Scheiße erzählen, es ist nicht von VM zu VM.
Es ist von VM zu, zu einem Raspberry-4.
Okay, so und jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal aus.
Über VPN.
So und dann können wir wahrscheinlich einfach hier unseren, unseren Host nehmen.
Das 10 10 10 10 1, jawoll.
10 10 10 1.
Ja gut, es ist ein bisschen langsamer.
Es ist ein bisschen langsamer.
Ähm, wie macht man unlimited duration? Geht das irgendwie IPerf?
Kann man da irgendwie duration einstellen?
Dass der einfach permanent macht.
Ich mein, man konnte count machen oder sowas, ne?
Das hatten wir doch erst letztens.
Hier minus T 60.
Das hatten wir doch erst letztens, ist das gleiche Problem.
60, minus T 60.
So, also.
Wir kriegen ungefähr 36 Megabytes die Sekunde über das VPN mit einem Raspberry.
Der Raspberry, schauen wir uns mal die Auslastung an.
Der ist halt ganz gut beschäftigt.
Ein Kern auf Anschlag und die anderen auch ganz gut dabei.
Gut, IPerf selber macht natürlich noch ein bisschen CPU Last.
Das andere sind irgendwelche kernel Module, die sehen wir jetzt hier nicht.
Aber es ist nicht schlecht für einen Raspberry.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab den Raspberry noch nie ausprobiert.
Hast du mal auf einem Raspberry OpenBSD, nein, hab ich noch nie probiert.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Raspberry Pi OpenBSD Builds gibt.
Aber eigentlich ist es logisch, dass es welche gibt.
Also ich kann es nicht vergleichen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was man an OpenVPN mit einem Raspberry durchkriegt.
Hat er vielleicht einer von euch Erfahrungen mit, ich weiß nicht, was man durchkriegt, OpenVPN.
Wir können mal gucken, ob der jemand anderes Erfahrungen hat.
Schauen wir mal.
What speed can be attained OpenVPN on P3?
Wir haben deutlich mehr als 30 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Wir haben 36 Megabyte die Sekunde.
Wir haben quasi zehnmal mehr ungefähr als die Typen hier.
Das ist aber auch der Dreier.
Mit OpenVPN.
Mit 0.
Ja, okay, das ist natürlich wirklich langsam.
3-4 MB.
Guck mal, hier schreibt einer sein P3.
Kriegt gerade mal 3-4 MB durch, durch OpenVPN.
Also wenn wir der Sache mal so glauben und das ist ein 4er und sind mal großzügig und sagen,
dass der 4er OpenVPN das doppelte schafft, nämlich 8 oder sagen wir mal aufrunden mit 10 MB,
dann ist WireGuard doch ganz schön schnell.
Also da kann man nichts sagen.
VPN mit 35 MB die Sekunde über den Raspberry laufen ist schon ordentlich.
Hast du mal von Arch auf einen Raspberry probiert?
Das können wir eigentlich machen.
Ich installiere mal den gleichen Krams jetzt mal auf meinem Host.
Erst noch mal hier kurz gucken, wie viel wir da haben.
Okay, also von meinem von meinem Linux kriegen wir auf die auf den Raspberry noch mehr.
Da sind wir knapp am theoretischen Gigabit Maximum.
Flutscht richtig gut.
Direkter Vergleich mit OpenVPN wäre interessant.
Ich habe keinen Bock, OpenVPN einzurichten.
OpenVPN einrichten ist der Horror.
Nur IPsec ist noch komplizierter.
Das ist das schöne bei so Cisco Dingern, wenn man einfach nur 2-3 Befehle ausüben,
ob VPN ist aktiviert und an, aber nicht auch VPN.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt im Arch-Wiki einen Eintrag zu.
Jawoll.
Ich brauche das alles gar nicht.
Ich brauche den WireGuard.
WireGuard Download.
Wie heißt denn das Ding?
Arch.
WireGuard Tools, WireGuard.
Ach so, das ist doch im Prinzip das gleiche, was ich hier auch drin hatte.
Sehe ich das richtig, dass Client und Server quasi in einem ist?
Könnte ich jetzt hiermit auch einen Server aufmachen oder was?
Nee, oder?
Oder doch?
Was machst du? Ich probiere WireGuard VPN aus.
Doch, ich glaube, ich könnte damit wirklich einen WireGuard aufmachen.
Ok, dann ist Client und dann ist das das gleiche.
Ok, dann installieren wir den mal. Jetzt brauchen wir eins und zwei brauchen wir.
Yes.
Ich glaube, ich muss noch ein Update machen.
Das Minus Force lassen wir mal weg.
Ok, ich muss ein Update machen, dann funktioniert es wahrscheinlich auch.
Omega Lul.
Relation.
Example Config.
Testing Tunnel.
Wie baut man jetzt hier eine Verbindung auf?
Das haben wir alle schon gemacht.
Hat das jemand schon mal gemacht?
Wie connecten wir man sich jetzt von einem Linux aus?
Zu einem WireGuard Server, wahrscheinlich auch damit. Und dann WG, WG, irgendwie Config Datei oder so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Und dann mal gleich sehen, wie das funktioniert.
Ok, also musst du die Kram erst mal installieren.
Ach so.
Ach so, ja das ist ja simpel.
Dann nehmen wir einfach unsere Client1 Conf.
Und connecten das damit. Ja, das müsste doch eigentlich funktionen.
Ok, wir müssen mal rebooten, weil kernel update unser Zeug.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, was wir da für eine Performance drüber kriegen.
Altes Profil. Connecten wir uns auf den Raspberry.
Noch ein Stream. Ja, heute probieren wir mal WireGuard VPN.
Steht schon eine Weile auf der Agenda. Was passiert hier eigentlich? Ich versuche eine VPN aufzubauen.
Zwischen Windows und dem Raspberry haben wir es schon gemacht.
Und zwischen meiner Linux Kiste und dem Raspberry probieren wir es jetzt.
Dann wollen wir mal gucken, wie schnell das Ganze ist.
So, dann kompilieren wir mal eine Runde.
Wenn der Max weiter so fleißig streamt, kann er sich bald Gamer Grill Badewasser leisten. Oh ja, unbedingt.
Da kann ich mir nicht nur bald Gamer Grill Badewasser leisten.
Da kann ich mir bald ein komplettes Gamer Grill leisten, wenn ich weiter strebe.
Aber dazu muss ich erstmal Partner werden.
Ohne Partner geht da nichts.
Oh, Sebaro. Warum weißt du sowas? Warum erweist der Sebaro sowas immer?
Twitter. Ja, klar. Twitter.
Wir müssen uns übrigens nachher noch den Max FPS beziehungsweise Wupplors Discord angucken.
Jetzt müsst ihr noch mal euren Cent dazu geben.
Also in Form von, was wir für Channels brauchen und Emotes und Zeug.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob der Gram jetzt funktioniert.
Die kleinen Config, die können wir uns ja einfach kopieren.
Da brauchen wir ja gar nichts Großartiges.
Ist es doch, ja. Das ist doch die kleinen Config.
Ich sag euch, dieser Clipboard meiner Scheiße ist übelst praktisch hier.
Oh, nee. Ist das falsche, was ich kopiert hab. Aber im Prinzip ist der sehr praktisch.
So, connecten wir uns exakt mit der gleichen IP und allem, wie vorher.
Wie von Windows aus, von Linux aus. Jetzt muss ich nur mal gucken, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Sagt man jetzt einfach WireGuard? Nee. WireGuard?
WireGuard, wie ging das jetzt? WireGuard up?
WireGuard up?
Ah nee, wie geht quick? Weil, auch immer quick. Klein1, nee.
Up, Klein1. You must be rude. Ja, okay.
Ach so, okay. Ist gut, machen wir. CP, home, max, nee, home, test, klein1, conf, nach etc, WireGuard.
Etc, WireGuard, und dann braucht das Ding mit Sicherheit noch die richtigen Credentials.
W, WG quick, up, Klein1.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert oder nicht? Resolve conf not found.
Okay, hab ich anscheinend bis jetzt noch nicht gebraucht.
Resolve conf. Ahja.
Open, Resolve conf. Warum hab ich eigentlich keine Resolve conf?
Keine Resolve conf. Aber kein Befehl, okay, was auch immer. Tja, was installieren wir da jetzt?
Keine Ahnung. Da. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Bam, nee. I, doch, hat funktioniert.
Bam, funktioniert. Sehr schön, nice.
So, und jetzt machen wir mal den gleichen Performance-Test nochmal.
Also wir haben den hier, das ist ohne VPN. Ohne VPN kriegen wir quasi über die gleiche, also die gleiche Strecke mehr oder weniger, ist das ja zum gleichen Zielsystem,
kriegen wir knapp einen Gigabit hin und über VPN kriegen wir ungefähr das gleiche wie unter Windows.
Ein bisschen schneller wie unter Windows, so ein paar MB, so 2-3 MB schneller als unter Windows.
Man nutzt nur einen Window-Manager, das ist i3-WM.
I3-WM hat ein komplett anderes Konzept wie die meisten anderen Window-Manager, weil es ist kein, es hat standardmäßig keine Windows in dem Sinne.
Ich meine, du kannst Windows machen, ja, aber standardmäßig ist es so, dass alles im Fullscreen ist und im zweiten Programm startet sich das quasi teilt.
Du kannst natürlich schon einstellen, wie es das machen soll und wie du das angeordnet haben willst.
Du kannst auch das raus machen zu einem Window, aber du verbringst eigentlich kaum noch Zeit mit Window-Management.
Guck mal, es hat sich jetzt eingependelt, ist jetzt ein bisschen schneller geworden.
Also wir sagen mal, es ist eher so 4-5 MB schneller.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Awesome, dass es nicht so viel Konfig braucht?
Ansonsten kannst du da ziemlich ähnliche Sachen machen, dann ist es einfacher zu konfigurieren.
Aber das ist nice, guck mal, im Durchschnitt 40 MB über einen VPN.
Was ist dein Ziel mit dem VPN?
Ich will gucken, wie schnell es mit einem Raspberry 4 ist.
Ich meine, der ist ziemlich am Anschlag, mehr geht da nicht.
Aber es ist nice, ich meine, OpenVPN ist schnell langsam dagegen.
Mit OpenVPN hätten wir vielleicht 10 MB die Sekunde.
Und mit WireGuard haben wir 40 MB die Sekunde.
Und wir haben das schon großzügig aufgerundet, was wir an Benchmarks, oder naja, was heißt an Benchmarks,
was wir an Ergebnissen zu OpenVPN gefunden haben, haben wir schon großzügig aufgerundet um mehr als das Doppelte.
Ist WireGuard das schnellste VPN, den du kennst?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich habe noch nie VPN, Bandbreiten, Benchmarks oder so gemacht.
Also auf dem passenden Gerät ist IPsec mit Sicherheit auch saumäßig schnell.
Aber WireGuard ist wirklich sehr zackig.
Ich meine, das ist ein Raspberry, das ist jetzt nicht, dass wir da was mit Superpower hinten dran hätten.
Also da bin ich echt positiv jetzt von, überrascht, dass das Ding 40 MB die Sekunde kriegt.
Und ich meine, man sieht es, der Raspberry ist dicht.
Man sieht hier zwar bloß 25% CPU-Auslastung, aber WireGuard ist halt ein Kernelmodul, das sieht man nicht so easy in dem Fall.
Und ich denke mal, dass der erste Core quasi komplett mit WireGuard zu ist und die anderen halt die Multi-Threading-Anteile von WireGuard.
Aber das ist nice, also es ist wirklich gut.
Und wenn man jetzt mal von aus geht, man verwende das Ganze mit, sagen wir mal, drei, vier Leuten oder so parallel.
Gehen wir mal von aus, ihr wisst nicht, Vater, Mutter, zwei Kinder.
Und jeder ist irgendwie per VPN mit seinem Smartphone, hat er da eine Verbindung aufgebaut.
Da könnten sogar, wohlgemerkt, wenn es die Internetverbindung daheim her gibt, könnten alle vier sich Full-HD Sachen streamen.
Locker.
Ist doch nice, also da kannst du wirklich nichts sagen.
Gut, man braucht erstmal eine Internet-Anbindung, die 350 MBit schafft.
Ich habe euch ja vorhin erzählt, ich habe die Telekom gekündigt und es gibt jetzt Unity Media mit 40 Up und 400 Down bei mir.
Da bin ich leider weit davon entfernt, dass ich WireGuard theoretisch ordentlich ausnutzen könnte.
Aber es ist trotzdem cool.
Der Winky sagt, er benutzt PIA als VPN, kenne ich nicht.
Was ist denn PIA VPN?
Achso, ich muss mal WireGuard ausmachen.
BG quick down, down, klein eins.
Jetzt geht mein Internet auch wieder klein.
Ist das PIA VPN?
Habe ich noch nie gehört, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist aber nichts, was du selbst hostest, oder?
Sponsor von Linux Tech Tips, gucke ich ganz selten.
Gucke ich auch eher wegen dem Entertainment-Faktor und nicht, weil man da so die Weisheiten erfährt.
Haben nicht Router schon oft eine VPN-Sache an Bord?
Doch, aber je nach Router sind die auch nicht sonderlich geschwind.
Oder aber deine Router kann nicht das VPN, was du verwenden willst.
Ich habe mir letztens sagen lassen, dass OpenVPN unter Mikrotik, hat jemand im Stream erzählt, wohl ziemlicher Crap sein muss.
Sowohl vom Speed her, als auch von der Implementierung her.
Kann ich weder B noch Wider legen, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert, ich könnte es ausprobieren.
IPsec kommt für mich nicht in Frage, weil IPsec, die Implementierung auf iOS ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Du kannst zum Beispiel keine unterschiedlichen Routen haben.
IPsec unter iOS kann nur alles durch den Tunnel leiten.
Und das will ich ja gerade mit einem Smartphone nicht.
Wenn ich mit einem Smartphone einen VPN aufmache, dann will ich nur eine spezielle Route oder zwei spezielle Routen übers VPN leiten.
Nämlich die, die in mein Heimnetz gehen.
Hier will ich komplett den Internet-Traffic durch meinen VPN schleusen.
Das ist so kompletter Blödsinn.
Ich will einfach nur die Route quasi für meine Nextcloud oder so will ich pushen.
Und das geht über IPsec mit, über iOS nicht.
Übrigens, weil wir gerade gesagt haben, Entertainment, ein richtig, richtig nicer Channel für Leute,
die sich ein bisschen auch für Elektronikkram interessieren, den ich übelst lustig finde, ist...
Der ist aber ziemlich groß.
Der hat auch schon 2 Millionen Abos oder so.
Nee, ist er nicht. Doch, hier der.
Der da. Electro-Boom.
2,6 Millionen Abos.
Und der macht das wirklich gut.
Der verbindet ziemlich gut quasi, dass man was lernt, mit lustigen Sachen.
Und er kriegt so ca. 10 Elektroschläge pro Video gefüllt.
Dann kriegst du schon immer Panik.
Ich mein, allein schon das Thumbnail sollte alle sagen.
Den kann man aber wirklich...
Den kann man sich aber wirklich angucken.
Der ist wirklich gut.
Das ist jemand, wo ich sag, voll verdient 2,6 Millionen Abos,
Informationsreiche Videos und gleichermaßen lustige Videos.
Der T-Max Electronics guckt den auch. Ah, gut.
Der hat auch schon Electronics im Namen. Ups.
Das Pepega-Board ist kaputt.
Was ist das Pepega-Board kaputt?
Ah, wegen VPN, ne?
Und wegen Reboot.
Pepega-Board ist kaputt.
Sind alle Fragen, hat es nicht aufgenommen.
Max-Software-Rip.
Hey, meine Software, so gut sie oder schlecht sie sein mag,
den Reboot überlebt sie noch nicht.
Wenn das mal einer erfindet, quasi Reboot-Proof-Software,
dann kann er was verdienen.
Wohlgemerkt auf dem gleichen Rechner weiterlaufen.
Ah, irgendwelche Sachen migraten oder so, kann jeder.
Muss ich übrigens mal sagen, dass ich es übelst nice finde,
dass ich gerade um die 100 Zuschauer hab,
bei quasi super random Laber-Stream ohne Ankündigung, ohne alles.
Freitagnachmittag, also Freitagnachmittag,
wo Leute noch arbeiten bis Freitagnachmittag.
Da ist das Pepega-Board wieder.
Laberstelz ist beliebt.
Müsste IPsec nicht bei IPv6 standardmäßig
für alle LTS-Verbindungen genutzt werden
und hat nicht direkt was mit VPN zu...
Hä?
Äh...
Oder?
Also es sei denn, die machen ganz merkwürdige Dinge bei IPv6,
was mich nicht wundern würde.
Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was IPsec mit TLS an sich groß,
also mit SSL oder HTTPS so groß was zu tun hat.
So, hab ich irgendwas im Chat überlesen.
Gibt schnelle OpenVPN Installer Bash Scripts weiter, weiter, fertig.
Die könnten das noch machen,
aber ich glaube, das müssen wir gar nicht ausprobieren.
Das wird deutlich schneller sein.
Ich schreibe mir aber mal in meine Stream To Do's auf,
dass wir das mal ausprobieren mit Android
auf VMWare laufen zu lassen, was es da gibt.
So.
Ankommen neuer Black Desert...
Äh, Black Desert...
Nee, Black Desert Spiel...
Ich habe jetzt meinen Account,
weil er irgendwie so eine No-No-Pay-To-Win-
ohne Cash-Shop-Account spielen will.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich jetzt wahrscheinlich mal wieder einlogge
auf meinen Account, habe ich da wahrscheinlich jetzt irgendwie
5 Level 62er mit Ultra Gear oder so drauf.
Und dann geht er immer ab.
Orange und Saft 9 habe ich gar nicht gelesen, Freund.
So, ist da Sebaro oder der Patrick am Start?
Oder beide?
Wollen wir uns das jetzt mit dem Discord...
Ah, alle beide, sehr gut.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mit dem Discord an.
Habt ihr da gerade Zeit für?
Ach so, wie ist denn mein Discord?
Ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen.
Mal gucken, dass mein Discord komische Dinge anzeigt.
Ich habe mal die Szene geswitcht.
Ich muss meinen Discord noch in Streaming-Modus stellen.
Genau, die Nudes der E-Grill sollen nicht direkt zu sehen sein.
Aber Patrick scheint sich da auszukennen.
Ach so, ist alles schon aktiviert?
Discord hat mich gerade eingeloggt, wieder ausgeloggt und wieder eingeloggt.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Passt wohl schon.
Okay, also, der Max FPS Discord-Server,
der Sebaro und der Patrick, also The Game 402 im Chat,
die haben sich das Ganze schon angeguckt und mal aufgesetzt.
Und was da jetzt standardmäßig drin ist, sind halt so ein paar Sachen,
wo sie gedacht haben, die passen gut zum Streamen.
Das heißt, wir müssen uns das Ganze jetzt mal anschauen
und gucken, ob das so passt, was wir machen können.
Ah ja, und wir müssen natürlich das Dark Theme einschalten.
Wo schaltet man in Discord nochmal das Dark Theme ein?
Ach so, stimmt, das ist...
Nur mein Chat ist nicht... Nur mein Chat ist nicht...
Der Chat ist weiß, ja gut, da kann man nichts gegen machen.
Einfach aufpassen wegen Sebaro seinen Monkathos-Bildern.
In welchem Channel hat der Sebaro Monkathos-Bilder gepostet?
Ich weiß, dass ich da nicht reingehe.
Ja, so ist doch viel schöner, oder?
Im Weebspam-Channel, da...
Außer in den Weebspam-Channel, okay.
Nicht, dass es jetzt hier Monkathos gibt wegen, weil das Sebaro Dinger spammt.
Also, was haltet ihr für sinnvolle Channels?
Also ich bin der Ansicht, ich hab mir das ja schon mal angeguckt,
ich bin der Ansicht, wir sollten mit ein bisschen weniger Channels starten,
weil umso mehr Channels man hat, umso mehr verteilen sich die Leute
und umso inaktiver und leerer wirkt das.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass das hier ein XQC-Discord ist,
wo wir dann auf einmal 150.000 Leute drin haben.
Also ich denke zum Beispiel, dass wir Off-Topic, Foodporn und Musik in einem machen könnte.
Warum Discord? Weil TS nur Gelaber ist, TS kaum einer verwendet
und Discord alle möglichen anderen Features hat.
Also ich denke, dass man zum Beispiel, genau, dass man das alles in einem machen könnte,
dass man Musik und Foodporn und Off-Topic alles in eins machen könnte.
Genau, so.
Ein Memes-Dings ist okay.
So, Ankündigung, da sieht man glaube ich immer, wenn mein Stream online geht,
das ist schon mal sehr nice.
Eingangshalle, braucht man die?
Ja gut, irgendeinen Default-Channel braucht man.
Wollen wir die vielleicht nicht Eingangshalle nennen, sondern irgendwie anders?
Irgendwie, habt ihr eine gute Idee, wie man das Ding nicht Eingangshalle, sondern...
General, ja.
Genau, einfach global irgendwas.
General finde ich ganz gut.
Nenn es einfach General.
Okay, Themenvorschläge, das ist ein Channel, den finde ich wichtig,
wenn irgendwie einem was in den Sinn kommt, wo ich mich mal darüber auslassen könnte.
Im Stream oder in einem Video, ja, also ab und zu soll das ja noch mal vorkommen.
Dann kann man es da rein klatschen.
Stream-Talk.
Wozu ist das gedacht?
MaxVideos in 2k19.
Text-Channel.
Wie Twitch-Chat nur oft...
Ah nee, da haben wir Twitch-Chat für.
Also ich denke, wir brauchen keinen generellen Chat und einen...
Stream-Talk.
Wir müssen uns auch mal über... Aber wir lassen es jetzt erst mal so.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob es hier wirklich so...
Weil die Frage ist ja, wenn man einen Channel off-topic nennt
und ein General, da weiß keiner so genau,
was kommt jetzt in off-topic und was kommt in general rein.
Vielleicht sollten wir sogar auch mal...
Oder Leute, was sagt ihr? Braucht man einen off-topic?
Weil ich meine, im Prinzip, wenn da nicht zu... Das machen wir dann, wenn zu viel los sein sollte
und zu viel gespammt wird oder so, dann können wir unterschiedliche Channels machen.
Aber standardmäßig können wir einfach einen general-Channel machen
und vielleicht später noch einen off-topic.
Themenvorschläge, den finde ich wichtig, das ist gut.
Stream-Soar. Ah, LOL.
Das ist ein Voice-Channel.
Der Voice-Channel für Streams ist gar nicht schlecht.
Falls ich mal irgendwann wieder was spielen sollte mit dem Eaxe oder so zusammen,
dann kann man das verwenden, das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Mal kurz nach das Putzen.
So.
Development-Text-Channels, ja.
Also, Proggers sollten wir auf jeden Fall behalten.
Ja, es ist Null. Ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns das mal an, wie viel da wirklich...
Was da wirklich kommt, ob es sinnvoll ist, dass man da noch einen off-topic macht.
Also, den Proggers-Channel sollten wir behalten.
Ich denke, wir brauchen... Also, ich glaube, den...
Also, ich würde sagen, den News-Channel in der Form braucht man...
Ich weiß nicht, braucht man einen News-Channel?
Weil...
Könnt ihr Channel-Beschreibungen in den Settings machen, dass die Leute das checken?
Das ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Das lassen wir erstmal so, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber Channel-Beschreibungen sind nicht verkehrt.
Technik-Chat.
Neuer in China-Crap.
Ich glaube, letztendlich wird es hier auch ein Channel tun.
Ja, was wäre geil, wenn man den off-topic-Channel per Bot-Command hervorruf...
Na, wir gucken erstmal, wie viel da wirklich ist.
Ja, wir gucken erstmal, wie viel da wirklich ist.
Ja, und vielleicht nennen wir das Ding dann noch irgendwie anstatt China...
Nennen wir einfach... Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht...
Vielleicht machen wir einfach...
Müssen wir uns einen guten Abend noch für überlegen.
So, und...
Das müsste eigentlich unter Developer-Channels...
Kann ich das selbst machen?
Ich mach mal lieber nichts selbst, ja.
War ich noch kaputt.
Und...
Ich glaube, wir machen...
Das geht nicht.
C-Route.
Also vielleicht sollten wir die...
Die verschiedenen Sprach-Channels...
Also die verschiedenen Channels der...
Mit den verschiedenen Sprachen sollten wir lassen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite...
Glaube ich, so viel wird's da nicht geben.
Das muss ich mir nochmal überlegen.
Das gucken wir uns nochmal an, wie das funktioniert.
Oder was wir machen.
Gaming... Also generell...
Könnte man nicht einfach sagen, wir machen...
Also diese...
Wir machen die Gruppen weg.
Wir machen einfach einen...
Progas-Channel.
Wir machen einen...
Nennen wir's mal Progas-Hilfe-Channel.
Wir machen einen Technik-Channel.
Und wir machen einen Gaming-Channel.
Weißt du, wie ich mein? Einfach...
Einfach, dass man ein bisschen weniger...
Dass auch erstens klar ist für jeden, wo was rein soll.
Und dass es weniger Zerstreuung dazwischen gibt.
Q-Chat.
Elektronik-Channel hatten wir schon.
Den haben wir mal weggemacht. Den können wir unter Technik einfach...
Hier guck mal, Highspeed editiert für das Ganze.
Sehr schön. Na ja, dass das gefällt, wäre schon viel besser.
Oh, wow. Ach ja, jetzt ist das...
So.
Ah, das ist... Hm.
Q-Chat.
Moment, darf ich Q-Chat aufmachen oder kommen dann die 18-Plus-Bilder vom Sebaro?
Weebspam darf ich nicht aufmachen, oder?
Wartet mal.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir lassen die... Genau.
Wir machen die Programmier-Hilfe-Channel das erste Mal weg für die einzelnen Sprachen.
Das hast du ja schon gemacht.
So, wir haben General, Ankündigung.
Das lassen wir mal drin.
Da können wir auch so Dinge machen wie, es gibt mal ein neues YouTube-Video oder sowas, falls es sowas gibt.
Themenvorschläge, Streamsore, Voice-Chat.
Progas-Hilfe.
Ja.
Q-Chat.
Lava-Stell 1 und 2.
Und Admin-Gedöns.
Das reicht doch erst mal.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt relativ zusammen gestaucht, das Ganze.
Gibt es noch irgendwas, wo ihr sagt, das sollten wir...
Nee, lass mal, ich frag den Fabian.
Außerdem weiß ich nicht, inwieweit das die Leute interessiert.
Die weißen wahrscheinlich gar kein BDO.
Oh, hier gucken.
Man könnte das höchstens als Command irgendwie machen.
Genau.
Habt ihr noch irgendwelche Vorschläge, was wir unbedingt machen sollen, müssen?
Weil ansonsten würde ich sagen...
Oder kommt drauf an, was der Patrick und der Sebaro sagen, können wir schon mal einen Invite-Link erstellen.
Also wenn alles passt und wenn Berechtigungen passen.
Wir machen kein Hentai-Channel, das ist Monkathos.
Klick ich dann im Stream aus Versehen auf den falschen Channel und gleich Instant-Bun.
Da ist es schon, der richtige Link.
Nice.
Sehr schön.
Ach so, ja übrigens, ich hätte noch einen Emote-Vorschlag.
Anstatt dem da, brauchen wir den Monkar Giga, den ich im Chat habe.
Den mit den großen Augen ohne rangezoomed.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar meinen Keks als Emote.
Aber ohne...
Oh, da brauchen wir noch einen transparenten Keks.
Ja, Emotes müssen wir noch ein paar hinzufügen.
Noch zwei Wochen, okay.
Ja, ich habe einen transparenten, ich habe eine transparente Variante von meinem Keks.
Okay, nice.
Ähm, kann man den Channel noch max.
Max FPS oder so nennen?
Weil es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen, die tatsächlich nur, nur das von Twitch kennen.
Oh, da geht es einfach unbedenklich.
Ach so, perfekt.
Willst du deinen Twitch-Handle behalten?
Du meinst den Name auf Twitch oder was?
Warum nicht?
Ach so, der Strich?
Hä, was meinst du?
Kriegst Jons?
So, ich mache den Rest mal wieder aus.
Der Tester hat ja wunderbar funktioniert.
Ja, die gesperrten Channels siehst du wahrscheinlich jetzt nur, weil ich hier im Stream eingeloggt bin, denke ich mal.
Jaja, wo bloß will ich behalten?
Du meinst, warum ich mich nicht auf Max FPS auf Twitch nenne?
Ähm, jetzt liegt...
Ja, eigentlich ursprünglich war es mal einen privaten Account, wo ich überhaupt nie vorhatte damit was zu streamen.
Ähm, auf der anderen Seite finde ich es insofern ganz gut, weil es gibt auf YouTube auch noch genug Deppen.
Und die bringen das hier dann gar nicht mit in Verbindung.
Also ich lasse das erstmal so.
Ich könnte mich sogar glaube ich jederzeit umbenennen, weil ich glaube ich habe mir Max FPS damals sogar auf Twitch gesichert.
Das heißt ich verfüge auch über den Account dann.
Ja, mal gucken, aber ich werde das... und man kann sich jetzt ja umbenennen, aber ich werde...
Ah ja, okay. Mikrophone, Spakt.
So, sehr nice, da können wir mich austoben im Discord.
Mal schauen, was wir damit in Zukunft noch machen.
Oh, da sind sie hier unter sich jetzt. Das darf ich, ich weiß jetzt schon, das darf ich im Stream nicht aufmachen.
Nee, nee, Miraki. Mirikari. Es ist ein Unterschied ob du den gleichen Namen hast.
Sehr schön. Ja, mal gucken was wir damit machen.
Ich hatte mir ja schon vor Ewigkeiten mal einen Discord angelegt hier unten.
Da bin ich aber nur mit dem Fabian zu zweit drin und mache nichts.
Wir machen noch einen Discord. Discord Command machen wir noch.
M-Core and Friends, den gibt es auch noch.
XQC, warum bin ich eigentlich bei XQC gejolt?
Ich glaube da weil der mal irgendwann Overwatch Games, OVL Games quasi kommentiert hat bei sich im Channel.
Okay, nice. Da haben wir die Discord Sache jetzt auch gestartet.
Da klicke ich jetzt nicht drauf, wer weiß was da drin ist.
Also wenn es irgendwelche Themen gibt, wenn irgendjemand Hilfe bei irgendwelchen Programmiergeschichten braucht, bei irgendwelchen Elektronikgeschichten.
Ach ja, sollen wir vielleicht noch einen Heimautomatisierungs Channel machen?
Oder passt der hier bei Technik ganz gut hin?
Dann lass uns doch die Development Channels, lass die mal einfach Technik oder so nennen.
Und dann machen wir einen Progas Channel und einen Heimautomatisierungs Channel und rest können wir so lassen.
So und Hilfe können dann die Leute rein spammen, die Pack-A-Loss haben oder wo die Portweiterleitung auf die Playstation nicht funktioniert.
Was wir alle schon im Stream in letzter Zeit hatten.
Weil das funktioniert einfach deutlich besser, als wenn ich da im Stream zwei Minuten mal meinen Senf dazu gebe, weil man kann vieles einfach nicht richtig diagnostizieren.
Und wenn da aber irgendwie einer Zeit und Bock hat den Leuten zu helfen, wäre das natürlich nice.
Sehr schön.
Das gefällt mir.
Hier unten werde ich im Stream nicht draufklicken, da habe ich zu viel Angst, dass der hinter der Zeug postet.
Progas.
Ja Leute, 2 Stunden 46 schon wieder.
Ich würde sagen, die Zeit geht immer viel schneller rum, als man denkt.
Ja sogar der Musikstream ist fast vorbei.
Für das, dass wir nichts vorhatten, haben wir wieder ziemlich viel gemacht.
Inklusive WireGuard VPN.
Und ich bin echt überrascht von der WireGuard Geschichte, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Vor allem die Config ist super einfach gewesen.
Ja gibt es noch irgendwas?
Ansonsten gehe ich jetzt glaube ich mal nur unter Abend essen.
Und ich glaube es ist auch für meinen Hals ganz gut, wenn ich nicht gar so lange laber, dass ich nächste Woche wieder fit bin.
Und vielleicht schaffe ich es ja.
Jetzt hier direkt im Anschluss, ich hole mir einfach was zu futtern.
Dann setze ich mich wieder an den Rechner und mache mal meine Partnerbewerbung für Twitch.
Was hältst du von der Idee in der 1066 zum Adcoden in deinem PC einzubauen?
Wenn die auch den guten Encoder hat.
Finde ich die Idee gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich spiele mir die ganze Zeit jetzt schon über NVEng.
Man merkt es jetzt nicht so richtig, ich meine statisches Desktop Zeug.
Was kostet eine 1066?
217 200.
Das könnte man sich tatsächlich mal überlegen.
Und Idle brauchen die Dinger jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viel Strom.
Ich glaube die können mittlerweile sogar H265 oder?
Ich meine sogar der Raspberry kann H265.
Das finde ich sogar keine schlechte Idee, das probiere ich vielleicht aus.
Habe ich hier eigentlich mit Company 3 auf?
Nutze deinen Raspberry zum streamen, easy.
So machen wir es.
Ich finde es lustig, es weiß keiner was dazu.
Wir machen einfach H265 in Assembler.
Easy.
Ja kann ich mich denn Partner bewerben jetzt?
Habe ich genug gestreamt?
Für Partnerschaft bewerben.
Wir müssen nur einige Dinge prüfen bevor du dich für eine Partnerschaft bewerben kannst.
Du musst eine verifiziert E-Mail Adresse besitzen.
Hast du bereits ein festes Publikum auf YouTube oder Twitter?
Ja, Twitter.
YouTube muss ich noch connecten.
Ich mache das hier gleich im Anschluss vom Stream.
Ich wurde jetzt die letzten Tage ja so gedrängt endlich mal mein Partnerschaft da zusammenzukriegen.
Da wird echt bald Zeit.
Pushst du eigentlich noch die aktuelle Version vom Meanboard?
Die aktuelle Version ist Müll, also die aktuelle Version funktioniert bei mir lokal und ist total unsauber und crap.
Was ich mal wirklich pushen könnte ist das Pepega Board.
Also die Chatgeschichte.
Da müssen wir allerdings noch eine Sache einbauen.
Das mache ich vielleicht im nächsten Stream.
Wir müssen das ein bisschen customizable machen.
Dass man nämlich die Channel und sowas customisieren kann, weil ich glaube es will keiner eine Chat mit Log Software haben, die hardcoded auf Wubblos geht.
Willst du den Twitch-Namen so lassen oder auf Max FPS ändern lassen?
Also prinzipiell würde ich sagen, ich lasse es so.
Allerdings würde ich mir dann vielleicht an der Stelle sogar auch mal anhören, was da Twitch dazu sagt, was sie vorschlagen, wenn sie denn was vorschlagen.
Ich gehe nämlich mal davon aus, dass die sagen werden, es wäre auf jeden Fall besser sich umzubenennen, dass es mehr Leute finden.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das halt so eine Sache.
Gerade deshalb habe ich mir nicht so genannt.
Ich habe ja den anderen Channel.
Ich muss mal gucken, habe ich den?
Twitch
Mal gucken, wen man findet.
Ich bilde mir aber ein, ich habe den Channel irgendwo.
Naja, aber das muss ich mir mal überlegen dann.
Ok, dann gehe ich jetzt was essen.
Es war wieder nice, dass ihr alle am Start wart.
Auch wenn das heute ein bisschen planlos war, weil wir eigentlich gar nicht genau wussten, was wir machen sollen, haben wir trotzdem noch ganz sinnvoll gefüllt die Zeit.
Gucken, ob jemand on ist, den man hosten kann.
Dem folge ich denn, den ich hosten möchte.
Ich habe keine Leute mit 12k, das ist komplett beknackt.
Cyrus könnte man wieder hosten.
Ich würde allerdings gerne lieber mal einen kleinen hosten.
Wir gucken jetzt noch mal schnell wer.
Auf Twitch.
Wer Science Techno, wer Web Programming streamt, gucken wir jetzt mal.
Ich finde diese Karte gehört immer an wie Scientology.
Air, Earthquake, 3D, Live, was, was, was gibt es auf Twitch alles?
Ja, wir brauchen auch ein Ausrufezeichen Discord Command.
Der Sebaro weiß aber, wie man das über den Chat anlegt.
Ich kann das anlegen über das Admin Interface.
Was ist das?
Man sieht, wo es Erderschütterungen gibt oder so.
ASP.NET Core 2.2 Workshop.
Du hast keine Rechte zum Command anlegen?
Klar, du musst Rechte zum Command anlegen haben.
Weil fast alle Commands, die mittlerweile angelegt sind, habe ich nicht selbst angelegt.
So, kann man das Filter nach German Language?
Aua, 3D Printer.
Was ist das für ein Stream?
Es ist einfach die Octoprint Kamera am 3D Printer dran.
Warum?
Warum streamt man seinen 3D-Drucker?
So kann man auch Views bekommen, ja Wahnsinn, viele.
Ist das ein Prusa?
MK-Dings 3?
Sieht von den Farben ein bisschen so aus.
Genau, Remote-Überwachung nur in Billig.
Wirtschaft für Schüler und Studierende.
Ihh, BWL-Kram, geh weg.
Java?
Was wird das wohl?
Ich würde sagen ein 3D-Drucker.
Was haben wir hier zu bieten?
PHP?
Das ist ja mal was.
Hab ich nicht mal gesehen.
Gäbe es jetzt irgendwelche deutschen Programming-Grills, die Programmen würden, dann würde ich natürlich sofort den Host raushauen.
Aber so wie das halt ist in der IT-Landschaft, zum größten Teil nur Typen am Start.
Oh nee, jetzt habe ich wieder was gesagt.
Jetzt sind wir ja gleich die Feministen am Start.
Ich darf es dir heute nichts mal sagen in der Richtung, ganz ganz gefährlich.
Java-Game-Engine, ich glaube wir hosten den Java-Game-Engine-Typ.
Oh, das sieht kompliziert aus. Und das ist Java.
Oder? Will man aber hosten? Den PHP? Den Typ mit PHP?
Ist das nicht der Typ von Unge hier?
Ist das nicht der Typ von Unge?
Sieht so aus, oder? Das war er doch.
Wer hat die Methoden-Namen auf Deutsch?
Wer hat seine Methoden auf Deutsch? Das ist doch mal was.
Ich sehe hier keine Methoden auf Deutsch.
Ja, warum nicht? So, mal was.
Was gab es Fehler? Ich sehe es überhaupt nicht.
Wo ist es, Leute? Guide mal meine Maus hin. Wo steht das?
Twitch Plays Maus. Ach, hier.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er seine Methoden-Namen wirklich Deutsch macht.
Das ist mit Sicherheit für ein Stream.
Weil es gibt doch Lichtelement und lokales Licht.
Jeder wie er will, das sagt überhaupt nichts aus.
Ihr könnt ihn noch mal fragen. Wir hosten ihn jetzt.
Ihr könnt ihn noch mal fragen, warum seine Methoden-Namen auf Deutsch sind.
Er macht ihn aber nicht gleich schlecht.
Sagt es mal den Franzosen, die alles auf Französisch schreiben.
Seid nett, Leute, seid nett. Also Leute, bis denn. Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.